Komm morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Union du wirst Siegen glaub an dich und es wird wahr die erste Bundesliga ist für uns zum Greifen nah die Zeit ist nun gekommen
ihr werdet alle sehen der erste fC Union wird und endlich oben stehen.
Hätte ich gekommen zur Lage der Union mein Name ist Linus Neumann mitnehmen Studios.
Intro
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 303 die Baseline unter den Netz politischen Sendungen heute ganz im Schatten der Weltpolitik.
Erzählen Tim vom vom Aufstieg des 1.FC Union.
Ist jetzt alles gesagt man muss mehr muss man nicht wissen aber es geht ein Ruck durch diese Stadt.
Ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht dass du nicht heiser bist was bist du für ein pennen also borio.tv.
Wusste dass ich mit dir noch eine Sendung heute aufnehmen werde ich habe mich bisschen zurückgehalten.
Union Fan Netzpolitik ultra.
Ich war am Ende fast der einzige der noch sprechen konnte.
Ganz neidisch am Ende noch in der Bahn zurück noch singen können nicht da konnten gestern ich war auch in einer Bahn mit Union Andi konnten nicht mehr.
Ja das ist von Allah.
Also das CityVille konnten wirklich die haben ehrlich weil dieses schöne leise schreien weißt du da könnt ihr bitte leise schreien.
Heilige macht er.
Ja so erstaunlich was dafür der Energie freigesetzt wurde es wird es noch eine Weile nachhalten aber jetzt haben es mal alle gemerkt.
Dann kriegt er halt nächstes Jahr in der ersten Liga so richtig schön ein Opfer Mappe jetzt Internet.
Katjes international geweihter Vokal.
Erster Pokal noch ja dann.
Wollte machen, eigentlich mit euch über Politik unterhalten.
Die die wir haben eine.
Wir haben eine Europawahl gehabt wir haben eine akk47 danach.
Vollem Anschlag.
Wir wollen in den Timer Krieg ziehen auch gegen Journalisten und Julian Assange und wow.
Außerdem müssen wir noch Klarnamenpflicht besprechen passenger Name record DNS Hijacking und die dsgvo und wir müssen uns ranhalten deswegen kommen wir zum Thema oder Europawahl.
Europawahl.
Hatte da auch noch Sinja Iliane.
Europawahl Europa war nicht das funktioniert nicht so ganz genau.
CDs in Europa war Papa Papa hallo Papa für alle.
Gollus lake.
Ja was gibt's zu sagen also es wurde gewählt und es wurde enorm gewählt also die Wahlbeteiligung ist über Gesamteuropa in Norm angestiegen nicht ob der Schnitt liegt jetzt bei 50% das ist ein Rekord.
Also Deutschland Lager bei Fallers ein 60% oder wie sowas und ich denke das hat auch erheblich zu den Ergebnissen beigetragen denn was ja nicht passiert.
Ich würde auch sagen tim also erheblich die Wahlbeteiligung hat erheblich zu ein Ergebnis mal getrennt ich würde sogar sagen jede die sich nicht an der Wahl beteiligt haben könnten unter Umständen überhaupt nichts mehr Ergebnis Baguette.
Doch natürlich tun sie das natürlich normalerweise immer aber halt jetzt nicht mehr in dem Maße wie sonst.
Ich meine These ist schlicht eine hohe Wahlbeteiligung hat unter anderem dazu geführt dass der so gefürchtete rechtslastige Einbruch.
Nicht in dem Maße stattgefunden hat soll es ist ein 10 Thema und in vielen Ländern ist es ja auch komplett anders gekommen Holland ist irgendwie SAKRET will das komplett.
Ausnahme ist natürlich Großbritannien natürlich immer noch im zerstörten Zustand sind aber auch da.
Sich an die Wirtin essen wie können ich meine guck 45 Minuten nigel Farage Ananas ok völliger völliger Clown.
Und ich kann auch verstehen dass viele Menschen jetzt diesen Impuls haben dem einen Milchshake an Kopf zu werfen weil der ein Gesicht hat für einen Milchshake.
Ja das ist auf jeden Fall der ist prädestiniert aber gut wie meine Großmutter den lasse ich glaube ich auf die einfache Formel bringen die Leute haben für die Parteien gestimmt.
Eine ganz ganz klare Haltung zum brexit haben.
Und Tori und labour haben deshalb so mega abgelöst weil sie das genau nicht haben,
und die lippecamp sind teilweise stärker als Lehrer geworden und,
bahnt sich jetzt sozusagen die Möglichkeit an einer einer einer tektonischen Verschiebungen dieser Parteienlandschaft die hoffentlich langfristig dann auch mal endlich zu der Erkenntnis führen wird dass sie mit ihrem Wahlsystem,
so nicht mehr weitermachen können weil es einfach in der neuen Konstellation nicht greift das kann das alles was Gutes sein natürlich ist das Land nach wie vor gespalten und wie man sich halt auch so ein Vollhonk
wie verarschen dich mal in der zweiten Reihe stehen noch schaurige gestalten klar dass das macht uns irgendwie fassungslos aber
die Wahlen waren not about politics also es ist jetzt sagen es ist brexit ist das beherrschende Thema das muss vom Tisch es wird auch vom Tisch kommen.
Der wird nicht stattfinden der brexit die werden jetzt sich irgendwie die Tories wer sich ins neuen Führer geben vielleicht,
diesen anderen Vollhonk irgendwie diesen Boris Johnson dann ist es komplett vorbei mit den Tores dann bricht das total auseinander und wird mindestens zu Neuwahlen kommen müssen auf parlamentarischer Ebene deren Ausgang noch vollkommen unklar ist,
das Elend wird auch eine Weile weitergehen die wären auf jeden Fall nicht Ende Oktober raus dreht dazu sind überhaupt Nina Lage,
also reiten reiten 3 technische sie dazu nicht in der Lage und sind auch mental dazu nicht in der Lage und der Battle wird noch eine Weile so weitergehen so lange müssen halt die Caspar da im Europaparlament ertragen aber es sind ja auch viele gute Leute rein.
Fun in Deutsch deutsche Wahlergebnisse drittens hier nicht ne.
Ich habe ja dann auch für ich habe dann auch in Deutschland abgestimmt und.
Hast richtig also richtig gesagt dein Tipp ist aufgegangen ja.
Ja nee bei mir auch wichtig und letztlich denke ich.
Diese dieser unglaubliche Wahlerfolg der Grünen ist meiner Meinung nach hat wirklich dass das Potenzial zur Zeitenwende also das war jetzt mal so.
Potential zur Zeitenwende hat ist wie die SPD ich habe dafür also du kannst ja inzwischen ich hab den Geheimtipp wie du jedes SPD Wahl Bingo gewinnst ne.
Historisch schlechte Niederlage so kann es nicht weitergehen.
Gaben verstanden Personaldebatten würden der Partei jetzt schaden.
Schaurig schaurig ist's das schaue ich.
Ja die SPD ist jetzt in der jetzt in der also ich finde SPD hat jetzt auch den Point of no Return überschritten also wir haben jetzt X Chance verpasst klarzukommen,
und selbst wenn die jetzt Kevin Kühnert zum Chef wählen,
Ja und wirklich Pirouetten drehen und irgendwie irgendwann,
scheiß weglassen und mal wieder eine linke Partei werden selbst dann ist es schon zu spät die Leute sind jetzt weg die sind jetzt bei den Grünen die Jugend.
Setzt auf Grün in meiner alle unter 34 was war das 33% grün und irgendwie keine andere Partei kommt über 10% bei den unter 34-Jährigen ich dachte ich falle ins Essen.
Das ist wirklich unfassbar,
aber auch irgendwie nicht überraschend man ich wunder mich immer noch irgendwie diese 10% CDU-Wähler in dieser Altersgruppe herkommen aber dass sie wahrscheinlich vermeiden.
Ganz unabhängig davon ja ob jetzt die grüne Lage sind,
das auch zu liefern was jetzt alle von dir erwarten aber es ist ja eine ganz ganz klare Ansage dass jetzt das Thema Klimaschutz einfach Thema Nummer eins sein muss so und natürlich auch das Netz.
Hat natürlich CDU auch nicht verstanden.
Diese diese letzten fehlertheorie von Nico semsrott hat sich da ja.
Da ist wirklich was dran.
Äußerst äußerst schön gezeigt.
Insofern Kleid also wir können da noch hoffen dass es für diese ganze für dieses CDU Phänomen wird ist irgendwann eine eine biologische Lösung geben aber wir haben wahrscheinlich einfach nicht mehr genug Zeit,
insofern unterstütze ich hier die Forderung von Nico semsrott eben des also einfach einen höchst Wahlalter auf festzulegen.
Also halte ich für eine.
Den Verlust des Führerscheins.
Völlig in Ordnung in den ersten 18 Jahren und in den letzten 18 Jahren deines Lebens bleibst du lieber von der Urne fern.
Und dann kommst Du irgendwann rein in die Urne.
Sowas haben wir noch schöne schöne Wahlergebnisse es gibt ja auch Risiko Wahlen ja in der Laupheimer Gemeinderatswahl hat man sich 2019 erstmalig entschieden.
Das EDV-System pc-wahl einzusetzen also antizyklische Softwarenutzung er während alle wissen das kann man nicht mehr benutzen sagt Laupheim halt mein Bier.
Es geht und stellt fest zum Ende.
7 Stimmen zu viel angezeigt bekommen in pc-wahl aber die Ursache konnten sie nicht klären außerdem hätte die Rechner handyrechner zahlreiche Sachverhalte der Wahl in obersulmetingen,
obersulmetingen falsch dargestellt wer wir sehen,
es wäre nicht schlecht gewesen auf diese Regionen mit Internet zu versorgen weil dann hätten die vielleicht was da die vielleicht davon erfahren können dass das gar nicht so so modernist.
Also konnten leider unseren Podcast nicht runterladen.
Nee das konnten sie nicht müssen wir noch mal irgendwie in speech-to-text irgendwie als txt Datei.
Kids to f***.
Istituti Lex ja.
Die schönste Reaktion im ant-man also eigentlich war ja klar dass in dem Moment wo die Europawahl hinter uns.
Endlich keine Sau mehr was von rezo,
hören wollen würde ja es war also völlig klar dass die CDU mit dem,
Mit dem überstehen der 18 Uhr bzw 23 Uhr Marke am Wahlsonntag dieses Problem hinter sich.
Hätte haben können.
Wieder einmal sagte sich ein hochrangiges CDU-Mitglied halt mal meinen Pflaumenschnaps ich habe eine Idee.
Die Nachricht kam dass ich eine ganze Reihe von Youtubern zusammengeschlossen haben um einen Aufruf zu starten Wahlaufruf gegen CDU und SPD.
Habe ich mich gefragt was wir eigentlich in diesem Land los wenn eine Reihe von Jamal 70 Zeitungsredaktionen 2 Tage vor der Wahl erklärt hätten wir machen einen gemeinsamen Aufruf Welt bitte nicht CDU und SPD.
Wäre klare Meinungsmache vor der Wahl gewesen und ich glaube es hätte eine muntere Diskussion in diesem Land ausgelöst.
Und die Frage stellt sich schon mit Blick auf das Thema Meinungsmache was sind eigentlich Regeln aus dem analogen Bereich und welche Regeln,
denn eigentlich für den digitalen Bereich ja oder nein das ist eine sehr grundlegende Frage,
über die wir uns unterhalten werden und zwar nicht nur wir in der CDU und mit der CDU sondern ich bin mir ganz sicher in der gesamten Medien politischen und auch Demokratie theoretischen Diskussion in der nächsten Zeit,
das eine Rolle spielen und deswegen werden wir diese Diskussion auch sehr offensiv an.
Na dann mal viel Glück was sagt ihr eigentlich.
Also Didi der der historische Kontext der hat sich glaube ich der lieben Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer hier gar nicht erschlossen die haben sich den rezo ja nur ein gedreht.
Weil sie mit Upload Filtern auf das Internet los wollten und dann haben die haben die Youtuber.
Inklusive rezo und teenage Kritiker gesagt das ist aber Internetzensur,
oder hat die CDU gesagt nein Internetzensur kommt erst noch wartet mal ab wenn ihr hier weiter die Fresse aufmacht unglaublich.
Inzwischen hat dann auch noch die die Bild-Zeitung hat den rezo ja auch noch gedoxxt der tritt ja nicht unter bürgerlichem Namen auf.
Aber was hat sie hier veröffentlicht.
Name Adresse und so also wo er wohnt ich habe also,
es ist für mich sehr schwierig da habe ich eine leichte Beschränkung in meinen Recherche Fähigkeiten erstens ich muss mein halben netzwerkfilter ausschalten um überhaupt Bild zu sehen,
ich sehe immer nur Adblocker hast du nicht gesehen so da muss ich das erstmal ausschalten so dann steht da bildplus jetzt soll ich auch noch dafür bezahlen und das geht nicht,
ja
aber die distalisiert einfach nicht passieren und die Ankündigung da ist irgendwie so wo wohnt der junge Mann mit dem blauen Haaren lesen Sie hier nach dem Klick und bezahlen wo er wohnt und was er macht oder so ne also das typische Bild Dinge was sie machen er hat natürlich selber
vorher gesagt er wird er wird hier bedroht er möchte genau deshalb nicht seinen sein bürgerlichen Kontexte haben kann man sich auch,
sehr gut vorstellen dass der,
ja ich meine die Frage ist ob von so ein paar Rentnern mit Gewaltfantasien wirklich eine Bedrohung ausgeht aber trotzdem will man die nicht vor der Tür stehen haben.
Vor allem das ist ja dann auch so totaler Psychotherapeut werden die wahrscheinlich ohnehin schon hat in irgendeiner Form erleiden müssen aber es macht es nicht einfacher wie wäre beim Drachenlord gesehen haben.
Ja völlig also.
Er ist zweimal fragt sich wirklich also erstens was hat diese Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer geraucht also wirklich wie kannst du so so,
das ist schon wirklich also dass das in diesem Zeitpunkt zu sagen ja ist für mich wirklich also unabhängig von jetzt irgendwie.
Politischen Positionierung das Zeug von einem.
Hochgradigen politischen Mangel an Talent zu sehen wirklich zu sehen so okay wir haben es ausgestanden der dieser Riese war fünf Tage lang.
War wurde über nichts anderes gesprochen und alles was die jetzt hätte machen müssen ist die Schnauze halten ja und jetzt machst du wieder die wenn du heute auf Ihre Webseite gehst du irgendeine Zeitung anschaust ist das immer noch Thema.
Das ist super das ist spitze Sascha Lobo hat das in seinem Kommentar genannt Marathon im Fettnäpfchen.
NZZ.
Ich glaube ich glaube von hier Ronny Kraftfuttermischwerk meinte sowas wie Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer tritt nicht ins Fettnäpfchen die springt mit alter für die Friteuse.
Ja aber ich meine man kann aber wieder mal schön raus lesen was auch in der CDU Film finnbuild Selbstbild und Gesellschaftsbild vorher schon also dieses,
was bekommt ihr dazu uns überhaupt zu kritisieren und.
Ist ja auch so inhaltlich irgendwie letztlich ja auch überhaupt nichts entgegenzusetzen haben gegen das was der Isolde ausgebreitet wie auch.
Weil ist so offen.
Apo.com unfähig sind aber Haupt jetzt eine Sprache zu finden kann ich mal jetzt nur mit Youtubern oder jungen Leuten oder so wie das jetzt ganz gerne paraphrasiert will ich finde einfach diese Sprache ist generell schon verloren gegangen und sie leben in so einer,
insula ilusionista Kapsel in der sie denken das wäre schon alles richtig so,
und reagieren aber auch wirklich wie bekloppt meine was ja hier gesagt hat ist Soja.
Meinungsmache was sagt denn damit Meinungsmache er beschwert sich darüber dass ich Youtuber sich irgendwie positionieren gar nicht mal für eine andere Partei,
dagegen aber,
Angela Merkel selber hat deine Webseite offen mit irgendwie Slash prominente sowie unterstützen Angela Merkel und dann hast du da irgendwie jeden Schlagersänger und sonstige
Vollhonks irgendwie ich kannte die alle gar nicht was ich total froh dass ich mehr von den Youtuber einen kannte als von diesem prominenten die die CDU oder als Unterstützer aufgeführt hat,
Ja und also sozusagen Meinungsmache ist okay wenn es für uns ist,
aber alles andere Meinung anderer Leute gehören halt entsprechend unterdrückt.
Duden du musst das so sehen ne seid seit über 60 Jahren wird unsere Demokratie unaufgeregt gründlich und ausgewogen informiert.
Durch die Bild-Zeitung,
und jetzt ist aber jetzt jetzt kommt irgendeiner ne und da könnte ja jeder kommen.
Blauer arauner.
Warum komme dann dahin Meinungsmache es ist vor allem wenn man sich überlegt wie inkompetent und unqualifiziert die reagiert haben auf dieses Ding mit,
Wer ist Wahrheit nicht irgendein Meinungsmache Video sondern er hat halt für seine Meinung,
billige angeführt so ja und das sind wir als Meinungsmache zu diskreditieren dass es wird also das sind trumpsche Methoden ja da wünscht man sich eigentlich dass sie wie die SPD einfach sagen würden wir haben verstanden.
Und das irgendwie machen aber das also es ist es ist unwürdig ist es wirklich unwürdig und
kann nur sagen dass ich mir die Hände Reibe und hoffe dass sie sich weiter demontieren und hoffe dass sie das Gesundheitssystem weiter abbauen damit ihn die WLAN noch schneller weg sterben damit endlich endlich für solche,
Leute los sind einfach nur unseriöse,
Menschen denen es einfach an einer kompetenten sinnvollen Auseinandersetzung mit dem politischen Inhalten einfach nicht gelegen ist.
Audios ist betreibt ja auch Meinung.
Ja tue ich wenigstens stehe ich dazu.
Guck mal noch mal was so die CDU für uns an neuen Entwicklungen parat hat die so zum Segen und zum Glück aller in Deutschland.
Gedacht.
Also es gibt es gibt ja jede Sendung eine gute Nachricht.
Sie jetzt schon durch.
Die gute Nachricht war jetzt von Tims gute Nachricht war unionist hat zu Hause unentschieden gespielt.
Auswärts auch und deswegen.
Und ist damit aufgestiegen dass du da Tipps gute Nachricht meine gute Nachricht ist.
Horst Seehofer beabsichtigt 20/21 endlich endlich aus dem Politikbetrieb auszuscheiden der hat dann.
50 Jahre lang quasi im Politikbetrieb ausgeschieden und jetzt scheidet er wirklich aus,
es ist eine es ist eine eine,
einen eine schwere schwere Durststrecke wird zu Ende gehen nicht aber ohne dass Horst Seehofer noch ein paar schöne Ideen ausscheidet die wir dann hier irgendwie abwehren müssen es geht los.
Mit der aktiven Cyber Abwehr ein,
Thema was für Logbuch Netzpolitik immer wieder behandeln immer wieder besprochen haben ich glaube
Sendungstitel Hack und Back dann Frank Krieger war zu Besuch zu dem Buch das Constanze Kurz und er geschrieben haben mit dem Tisch aber wir setzen uns eigentlich damit seit Jahren auseinander.
Mit der ID quasi hacking von staatlicher Seite zu betreiben und jetzt ist es tatsächlich so dass von bmi und weiteren Ministerien getragen.
Hier eine Initiative auf uns zu rollt neben den vielen.
Rechtlichen und moralischen Problemen betrachte ich das ja im bisschen auch aus der Perspektive eines Heckers und eines Menschen der in der IT Sicherheit arbeitet.
Und habe hier häufig verschiedene Herausforderungen benannt bei dieser gesamten Situation das erste ist,
diese Idee spontan zu sagen hat das und dann hatten die Dart das geht halt nicht,
ein ein Hack braucht Vorbereitung und es ist wird nicht so sein das spontan die Leute zur Tastatur greifen und.
Einen Hack durchführen das ist I II Punkte wir immer wieder wiederholen ist wenn,
die Regierungsinstitutionen sich um.
Im hacking engagieren dann brauchen Sie dafür Schwachstellen ohne Schwachstellen gibt keinen hack,
sie werden diese Schwachstellen zurückhalten müssen und,
bitte lieber gesagt es gibt ja nur um einige wenige Schwachstellen ja von mir aus geht so ein einige wenige,
und um einige wenige Zielsysteme aber die Schwachstellen werden eben trotzdem auf allen Systemen sein und da die Systeme die die angreifen im Zweifelsfall auch weitverbreitete Systeme sind werden
wir als Bevölkerung wir als Menschheit auf diesem Planeten diesen Schwachstellen auch ausgesetzt sein das heißt hier wird.
In unser aller Unsicherheit investiert.
Unter dem Deckmantel das hier für unsere Sicherheit agiert würde und der dritte Punkt ist dass es denen sehr schwer fällt muss ich wirklich betonen.
Auch nur theoretische Fälle zu benennen,
in denen ein solcher Heck-Pack tatsächlich sinnvoll wäre unter der Maßgabe die sie nämlich selber nennen immer hier unter dem unter der unter der Motivation der Schadensminderung.
Und der Verteidigung ja sie sagen also spezifisch hier wenn.
Ein Angriff abzuwehren ist dann wollen wir Hack und Back und es fällt ihnen schwer.
Realistische historische Fälle zu benennen in denen tatsächlich ein Hack und Back mal gewirkt hätte.
Ja erstens gewirkt hätte oder hätte gewirkt haben können auch da gibt es wenige Beispiele effektiv reden siehe von,
Zweifel das ist einmal die Vertraulichkeit von etwas wurde verletzt ja also Daten wurden irgendwo extrahiert und müssen jetzt
wiedererlangt werden oder ihre Verbreitung,
gestoppt werden das ist der der eine Fall und der andere Fall über den sie sprechen ist die Verfügbarkeit von etwas wurde verletzt und wir müssen jetzt quasi einen anderen Server hacken,
damit unsere Verfügbarkeit wiederhergestellt wird ja beides relativ,
absurde Ideen wenn man sich darüber mal kurz Gedanken hat also erstens Vertraulichkeit Vertraulichkeit Verletzung Daten wurden extrahiert und jetzt steht da so die Idee im Raume.
Okay also wir haben um die wurden gehackt hier Bundestag Hack 2015 oder vanderwaal so und so viel Gigabyte sind aus unserem Netz an folgender IP-Adresse gegangen wir wissen das jetzt würden wir gerne diese IP Adresse hacken um die Daten zurückzubekommen ja also ein fundamentales Missverständnis
der Idee des Kopieren von Daten,
würden Angreifer sagen ach geil wir hätten wir hätten jetzt hier die deutsche Bundesregierung ziehen 60GB raus aber die Daten die wir da geholt haben die lassen wir natürlich nur auf diesem einen Server liegen.
Damit,
das reicht ja wenn wir sie dort haben ja die werden wir nicht noch mal kopieren damit reicht ja damit sie einmal haben ne wir sind ja genauso doof wie alle anderen und machen keine Backups also völlig völlig an den Haaren herbeigezogen,
Erwägung überhaupt sich einmal gestohlene Daten zurückzuholen II also B,
der Fall an den sich ja denken können,
ist darauf komme ich gleich noch mal zurück der Fall hier von Anfang des Jahres dass das Promi doxing ja von diesem Orbit,
der hat ja damals auch gesagt sehr gezielt alle Daten die er veröffentlicht hat immer bei mehreren shared house dann hochgeladen hat um es möglichst schwer zu machen die wieder aus dem internet zu löschen unspezifisch spezifisch,
fährt Haus der genommen hat für den jetzt deutsche Behörden nicht den schnellsten Draht entwickeln konnten,
da aber natürlich eine Frage von notice and Takedown die eindeutig da würde ich sogar mitgehen
offenbar hier nicht gut funktioniert haben ich habe ja selber bemängelt dass einige der Daten aus diesen Text noch in Siegen viele Wochen oder ich glaube über einen Monat später
noch verfügbar waren das darf natürlich nicht sein dass ein Mißstand Frage ist aber natürlich ist der durch hacking zu begleichen.
Oder eben nicht also auch hier sehe ich bei der Vertraulichkeit Verletzung sehr wenig Sinn in All-In Hack und Back.
Dann Verfügbarkeit Verletzung da gehen die ungefähr davon aus irgendwie von einem,
ein Server hat ein kontrolliert ein Botnet und dieses Wort nett,
mach jetzt was ich in die night of service Angriff auf wichtige Infrastruktur des Bundes und deswegen geht bei uns die Heizung aus klingt verrückt ist aber wahrscheinlich total realistisch wenn ich mir angucke wie diese Systeme abgesichert sind so jetzt gehen wir davon aus,
dass sie mit anderen Maßnahmen dieser an dieser Lage nicht Herr werden deshalb den command-and-control Server hacken müssen.
Und den irgendwie beispielsweise herunterfahren und bilden sich dann ein so könnten sie den Angriff beenden ja als würden die Bots die an diesem command and control Server hängen nicht,
beispielsweise Ihren Befehl einfach weiter ausführen solange sie keinen neuen von dem command-and-control Server bekommen ja auch hier,
selbst wenn man eine solche Situation konstruiert die es in der Vergangenheit wird dich kaum gegeben hat realistisch vertretbar aber selbst wenn man die konstruiert.
Stellt sich die Frage.
Was passiert denn was machen die Angreifer denn wenn mein einer command and control Server auf einmal gehackt wurde und weg ist dann ziehe ich den nächsten hoch ja also auch da werden sie nicht gezielt agieren können ich ich gebe hier.
An und zu dass es vor langer Zeit mehr Jahre her mal so ein Botnet takeover gab den haben glaube ich damals so Microsoft Leute gemachter gaskassier ein Botnet dass lange Zeit ihr Unwesen getrieben hat.
Lange beobachtet und.
Wie hat das Beobachter matt irgendwann in command and control Server gehackt und haben dann allen Boss dir dann daran angeschlossen waren quasi den Befehl zur selbst Desinfektion gegeben dass einer Jahre lang her.
Und einer der wenigen Fälle und interessanterweise dazu komme ich gleich würde er unter diesen Plan den sie jetzt haben nicht fallen so.
Komme zurück zu den Einträge würde ich am Anfang gesagt habe spontan hacken geht nicht so etwas muss vorbereitet sein und diese Vorbereitung das erkennen Sie jetzt hier auch endlich zum ersten Mal an indem sie nämlich sagen.
Hier ist irgendwie technisches Know-how erforderlich und das haben wir ja im Zweifelsfall nur an wenigen Stellen in Deutschland und,
wir dürfen ja quasi diese Sabotage Tätigkeit erst durchführen,
wenn wir den kompletten Prozess für diese Entscheidung getroffen haben und die Voraussetzungen dafür sind nämlich das ist ein,
erheblicher angefahrenes auf dem Ausland ist,
der sich gegen deutsche Infrastruktur einrichtet mit anderen zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln nicht mehr abgewehrt abgemildert werden kann.
Und dass Maßnahmen also hacking Maßnahmen zur Beendigung oder bedeutenden Abschwächung
im Einzelfall Erfolgsversprechen unverhältnismäßig sein können das sind die Voraussetzung dafür dass sie es könnten also muss erheblich gegen deutsche Infrastruktur inside das war jetzt bei diesem Botnetz z.b. nicht der Fall ja das war einfach das Botnet war einfach nur da.
Würde das Dina laufservice angeführt machen kannst das wieder auf Netzwerk Ebene abwehren und das ist das was hier aktuell in den Medien besprochen wird als der vier Stufen Plan.
Muss ich nämlich sagen ok die erste Stufe ist die Abwehr durch Verpflichtung Dritter also Daten Verkehre
müssen blockiert oder umgelenkt werden und dafür wollen wir ein anordnungsrecht haben um im Provider zu verpflichten beispielsweise zu sagen ok der shared Hoster hier der ist jetzt gesetzlich verpflichtet zu löschen was wir sagen was er löschen soll oder unsere ESPE sind gesetzlich verpflichtet,
Zugriffe zu diesen IP Adressen zu unterbinden kann.
In in besonderen wahnsinnigen Situation,
unter Umständen eine sinnvolle Maßnahme sein ich denke immer noch dass es wenige Fälle gibt in denen das auch eine effektive und nachhaltige Maßnahme ist aber ich würde den Streit erstmal nicht besonders,
Wald für dann Abwehr ohne Eingriff in ip-systeme.
Sagen Sie also okay die Diebe
Polizeibehörden des Bundes müssen die Umleitung oder Blockierung selbst vornehmen also was weiß ich der der shared Hoster ist irgendwo in Demut dem Land und jetzt muss jetzt müssen wir selber vornehmen,
den den Netzwerkangriffen ich schon mal
um einiges kritischer weil eigentlich wir haben nicht so viele 1-piece und wenn es jetzt irgendwie im im Cyber Notstand eine Anordnung gebe an was weiß ich die wenigen 1-piece oder von mir aus auch den de kriegst zusagen
diese IP-Adresse bitte nicht mehr Routen das macht uns hier gerade das Land kaputt würde ich.
Dann sagen sie Abwehr mit Eingriff in IT system wo sie also sagen ok es kann sein dass man in fremde RT Systeme
eindringen muss und ihr vielleicht mal was was löscht etwas entfernt oder inkriminierte Daten löscht der wo wir da kommen wir es jetzt in diesem
hacking Bereich oder fragt man sich der wie wollt ihr das es wird doch spontan einfach nicht gehen ihr redet ja immer von Sum Notstands Szenario und jetzt ehrlich sagen sie sogar noch
vierte Stufe wäre Maßnahmen auf die Funktionsfähigkeit des zum Angriff genutzten rt-systems einzuwirken also das System,
durch Eindringen und Herunterfahren einfach auszuschalten also Desinfektion oder löschen.
Dann haben sie sich endlich mal Gedanken darüber gemacht ja wie wenn wenn hacken gar nicht wenn der spontan hat gar nicht gelingt ja und wir das vorbereiten müssen,
wie machen wir das denn und wie geht ja hier immer also das wovon sie reden ist nicht das Eindringen das ein Ring ist immer nur Voraussetzung.
Die Schädigung ist das passiert sagen und dann haben sie sich überlegt wen haben wir denn der heute schon in fremde Computersysteme eindringt.
Den Bundesnachrichtendienst und der darf das zu Spionage zeigen der Bionade Hundetasche.
Bionade Dienst.
Der Bionade Dienst.
Wichtig hier Prenzlauer Berg.
Der Prinz.
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst in fremde Computersysteme eindringen um dort Spionage zu betreiben also vertraulichkeits Verletzungen.
Was der nicht darf sind,
Verfügbarkeit Verletzung oder tatsächliche Änderungen an dem System die über die Infektion selbst hinausgehen also was sie jetzt haben möchten ist unser Bundesnachrichtendienst der bisher so ungefähr gleich mal die NSA ist ja Spionage,
soll quasi ermächtigt werden dazu die CIA zu werden um eben in solchen Fällen,
auch tatsächlich aktive undercover Schädigung Maßnahmen vorzunehmen und.
Ich meine das ganze soll natürlich nach Deutsch mit deutscher Gründlichkeit irgendwie dann im Cyber-Abwehrzentrum von BND,
Bundeswehr Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz BST und Auswärtiges Amt und wer da nicht alles dabei sein soll geschützt sein aber der Schaden den wir für uns selber schaffen,
durch diese Vorbereitungen durch Schwachstellen die den wir dann alle ausgesetzt sind der ist da eben schon längst angerichtet wenn hier die Entscheidung tatsächlich.
Passieren würde und deswegen halte ich das für eine sehr sehr sehr kritische Entwicklung die,
zumal noch die Eigenschaft hat das dafür das Grundgesetz geändert werden muss denn die,
da diese Abwehr Kompetenzen sind eigentlich noch bei den Ländern da würde ich sogar auch noch mitgehen dass das wahrscheinlich sinnvoller wäre Abwehr Kompetenzen auf Bundesebene zu bündeln wissen 16 unterschiedliche
abwärts Zentren haben sodass der gehe ich noch mit aber bitte bitte bitte.
Doch in der Defensive investieren wenn wir uns anschauen was im Cyber die ganze Zeit los ist,
am laufenden Band komm irgendwo welche rein am laufenden Band werden irgendwo Daten gestohlen Daten gelöscht geht irgendwas kaputt sei was heimersheimer den ganzen Tag ja
und wo
nicht an mangelnden Gegenschlag Kompetenzen sondern an mangelnden defensiv Kompetenzen das ist das was wir erstmal in Griff kriegen müssen ich habe das verglichen,
mit wir haben jetzt hier einen kaputten Schild also brauchen wir ein besseres Schwert und das ist falsch das wird nicht gut gehen.
Wir müssen erstmal die defensiv Kapazitäten auf ein akzeptables Niveau bringen bevor wir irgendwo in den in den offensiven Bereichen mitspielen können wie der Tim aus dem Fußball sicherlich
bescheinigen wird du kannst nicht nur vorne spielen wenn du hinten nicht gut undicht stehst.
Aufstieg geht nur mit guter Tipp.
Aufstieg Aufstieg lasst euch das von jemandem sagen der mit einem Unentschieden aufsteigt zwei Unentschieden.
Mit nichts kann man komplexe politische Situationen und Konstellationen besser beschreiben als mit einfachen Fußball weiß.
Deswegen habe ich das ja auch zugelassen einmalig hier dass du einmal hier.
Das heißt ja einmalig da bauen wir einfach in Zukunft drauf auf.
Ihr wollt ja wohl nicht noch mal in die erste Liga aufsteigen ich will ja wohl meinen gewollter bleiben oder nicht.
Nach dem Spiel ist vor dem Spiel eine Legislatur dauert nur vier Jahre und dann geht's wieder von vorne los.
Nachdem nach dem Aufstieg ist vor dem Abstieg okay also passen wir zusammen.
Hier geht es darum die offensiv Kapazitäten auszubauen diese,
obwohl wir noch nicht einmal defensiv Kapazitäten in nennenswerter Form haben das heißt hier wird das Spiel in die Eskalation getrieben statt in die in die Defensive und die Deeskalation,
Abschreckung als altes militärisches Konzept funktioniert
im Cyber übrigens nicht das haben wir glaube ich auch sehr gesehen deswegen redet man hier von der hybriden Kriegsführung im Cyber können auf einmal irgendwelche anderen Leute mitspielen und realistische Fälle,
hat in denen das jetzt was die hier konzipieren irgendwie sinnvoll wäre sind sehr sehr selten und haben immer noch ein aber,
ja und historische Fälle gibt es so gut wie keine wo man sagen würde das was die da jetzt planen ist sinnvoll außerdem.
Offensiv quasi militärische offensiv Kapazitäten in die Hände des BND zu liegen wird.
In diesem in diesem Papier zitiert als aus fachlicher Sicht sinnvoll
ja aus fachlicher Sicht gerne vieles ist aus fachlicher Sicht sinnvoll aber allein hier die Zusammenarbeit dann auch von Polizeibehörden und Geheimdiensten zu verdichten das ist alles.
Ein ein ein Spiel mit einem Feuer für das Deutschland einfach auch nicht gewappnet ist muss man muss man dann auch einfach mal traurig,
sagen ne eine Strategie in so einem weltweiten Konflikt eines Landes muss ich ja auch ein bisschen da Nachrichten,
was man selber für Ressourcen hat was man für Kapazitäten hat und dann eben zu sagen ok was ist mit denen Möglichkeiten die uns zur Verfügung stehen die realistische und die einem die Gewinn,
dringendste Strategie und Deutschland ist eben gerade nicht unbedingt finden.
Für den Angriff gut aufgestellt wir sollten wenigstens gucken ob wir vorher unsere Segelboot repariert kriegen.
Na gut also ich sehe ein dass die große Koalition vielleicht doch nicht so gute Ideen hat aber dass das wird sie doch auch gewesen sein oder schlimmer kann's auch mit Seehofer nicht mehr werden.
Gerade gesagt die sollen sich nicht mit den großen anlegen deswegen hat sich Seehofer gesagt nachher okay vielleicht können wir ja wenigstens irgendwie.
Dickmanns Amelie klein.
Gläser mit den kleinen an wen könnten wir denn noch hacken Journalisten.
Ja super.
Journalisten können.
Die machen ja Meinungsmacher.
Die machen Meinungsmache.
Und es verboten.
Und das geht ja so nicht und deswegen haben sie jetzt einen Entwurf indem sie die Online-Durchsuchung umfassen neue Regeln Online-Durchsuchungen wir erinnern uns der übere,
der Uebler der Staatstrojaner Einsatz der während die Quellen-TKÜ rechtlich nur,
zugelassen ist zur Verletzung der Vertraulichkeit von nachrichten spezifischen Kommunikationen,
ist die Online-Durchsuchung quasi das okay einmal den kompletten Computer durchsuchen sehr stark eingeschränkt in seiner,
in den Straftaten bei denen die online besuchen überhaupt ein zulässiges Rettungsmittel ist und in dieser Neuregelung gibt jetzt einen Paragraphen mit der Überschrift Schranken nachrichtendienstlicher Mittel und der ist gibt dazu berufen.
An bei denen das nicht passieren darf bei Büro Berufsgeheimnisträger nämlich Priester Anwälte Ärzte und Abgeordnete,
und was normalerweise dann noch fehlt sind Journalisten und dieses neue Verfassungsschutzgesetz lässt dieses mit den Journalisten halt,
aus und sagt schwanzquaste spezifisch gemäß StPO bis Nummer vier sind eben die Nummer fünf und hätt so nah und doch so fern liebe Journalisten.
Wir wollen euch heute hacken der Status heute wäre wenn es um schwerste Straftaten geht
können Ermittlungsrichter das Anordnen ein Spähangriff auch auf Journalisten ja bei schwersten
Straftaten der Fähre aber nur die Quellen-TKÜ die nämlich 2006/2017 gesetzlich geregelt ist da war das war die Anhörung von der öfter normal berichtete wo ich irgendwie,
habe ich am Sonntag erfahren habe da sie am Dienstag,
im Bundestag sein soll oder Soldaten wie 48 Stunden 25 Seiten habe mir dann noch geschrieben um zu erklären warum das alles falsch ist wurde dann zu den Akten gelegt nächstes Mal mache ich ihn,
YouTube video.
Gutedel.
Und der muss da musst du auch dann wenn wenn man jetzt,
eine Quellen-TKÜ bei einem Journalisten machen möchte muss es ein Richter entscheiden den neuen Gesetz muss keine Straftat vorliegen soll es soll bereits genügen
wenn es sich um einen politischen Vorgang handelt der vom für den Nachrichtendienst von Belang ist,
die kennen alle die Belange des alten Nachrichtendienst Chef Hans-Georg Maaßen denn dann dürfte der Verfassungsschutz abwägen
nachrichtendienstliche Interessen schwerer wiegen als das Redaktionsgeheimnis also du darfst dann also abbiegen ob deine Interessen höher liegen als die Grundrechte die grundgesetzlich für für Journalisten mal vorgesehen waren
und lediglich das geheim tagende die die geheim tagende G10 Kommission früher.
Wird informiert darf aber auch keinem was davon hat.
Wird informiert dass im Zweifelsfall auf Nachfragen also das kennen wir ja aus unserem Interview mit Hans-Christian Ströbele in der lnt-100,
ja geil gute Idee es war immer eine Spitzenidee den Inlandsgeheimdienst gegen die eigenen Journalisten Vorgehen zu lassen da haben wir ja historischen Bomben Erfahrungen mit in in Deutschland gemacht das sehen wir in anderen Ländern wie gut das funktioniert,
Ja und danke Hotte sodass dass es wirklich noch mal eine bombenidee uns vor Augen zu führen dass wir auch,
in den letzten Monaten und Jahren deiner deiner politischen,
Tätigkeit keine altersmilde zu erwarten haben und wirklich nur entgegenfiebern können,
endlich dich los zu sein wenn damit die Menschen die bei dir im Hause arbeiten von denen so etwas ja kommt endlich wieder vielleicht jemanden vorgesetzt haben der nicht jeden Mist den sie vorlegen sofort,
in in Richtung der Realisierung Schlepp.
Aber ich denke AKK ist hier so vielleicht eigentlich müssten sie dann noch hinschreiben dass sie
achso der Youtuber sind ja dann für Youtuber gab sie keine Ausnahme insofern müssen erzähl nicht könnte man vielleicht noch mal explizit sagen Youtuber Youtuber die gegen die CDU was sagen die sollten natürlich auch
gehackt werden.
Visa Anwälte Ärzte in Abgeordnete.
Das dürfte so einen Querschnitt von CDU WLAN sein wie man sich nur irgendwie vorstellen kann so also im Wesentlichen sagen sie erzählt EU darf nicht abgehört werden auf diese linksradikal Journalist.
Wähler CDU.
Hörmann.
Ich hasse es ja übrigens wenn wenn Verschwörungstheorien.
War halt ne also sowas wie bin ich bin ja ein.
Ich bin ja immer sehr bemüht die Leute irgendwie faktenbasiert zu halten und.
Davor zu bewahren sich allzu wirren Verschwörungstheorien hinzugeben wie z.b. dass das Innenministerium dem Geheimnis auf die Journalisten hetzen würde oder dass die CDU einfach das Internet
zensieren möchte die Meinungsfreiheit einschränken möchte nicht dass und das möchten wir immer erst dann wenn es wirklich fakt ist,
z.b. wäre auch eine völlig absurde Verschwörungstheorie davon auszugehen dass die USA 17 neue Anklagepunkte gegen Julian Assange
raus fischt und jetzt in insgesamt bei 175 Jahren Haft ist die im Tron,
na das wäre ja eine völlig absurde Verschwörungstheorie wenn wir das seit Jahren gesagt hätten und davor gewarnt hätten.
Stellt sich raus isser.
Klingt verrückt ist aber so ja ich weiß leider gar nicht genau was das jetzt also dieser Anklagepunkte steht.
Höchste ja wenn der das da wenn das nämlich nur nach nach Jahren ist dass sie nämlich genau nichts mit Todesstrafe haben damit sie nämlich fein soll weil ich das immer noch so haben dass sie den.
Das Idee dass sie eine Auslieferung Aussehen falschen König,
Reich bekommen können wenn er seine Haftstrafe dir jetzt noch mal für die für die die Verstoß gegen die Bale Auflagen absetzt verbüßt hat insofern.
Da können da werden wir jetzt die entscheidende denen der entscheiden Kämpfe um die Pressefreiheit für die nächsten Jahre führen denn.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher dass die USA Julien erforscht nicht töten werden der ist den viel nützlicher wenn deine 175,
Jahre Haftstrafe vorführt ab absetzt und jedes Jahr einmal so noch mal an die Öffentlichkeit gehen darf,
um sein Erbarmen Erbarmen es würdigen Zustand kurz für die Öffentlichkeit zu dokumentieren und noch mal irgendetwas zum Weltgeschehen zu sagen um quasi noch mal alle zu warnen die sich mit den USA anlegen wollen.
Also hier sehen wir echt gefährliche.
Entwicklungen der Anklage nach Spionage Verrat militärischer Informationen.
Schwerer Schaden für die USA also genau diese diese ganze.
Diese ganzen Anklagen vor denen Journalisten und Veröffentlichungsplattform zum Glück bisher häufig verschont blieben und die hier eben dann auch der entscheidende wichtige.
Hebel für Pressefreiheit sind,
die auch z.b. in so Situationen wie dem Strache Video und sonstigen dann immer und den Panama papers immer wieder eine Rolle spielen und die die wichtigste der wichtigste Schutz sind wenn wir davon reden dass wir,
Journalisten als eine balancierende vierte oder fünfte Macht im Staate haben wollen zur Sicherung der Demokratie.
Also da können wir die Augen aufhalten.
Ja die Augen aufhalten ich würde sogar sagen die braune lupfen muss man auf jeden Fall rund um den Streit,
Umrah way der.
Elektronik Gigantos China der letzten Jahren ziemlich kometenhaften Aufstieg erfahren hat allerdings im bestimmten Sinn Menden schon länger eine große Rolle spielt.
Die Nachricht ist jetzt nicht ganz neu aber die Sache entwickelt sich immer weiter was passiert.
Es ging so vor ein paar Monaten los dass die USA und die haben da auch glaube ich auch schon mal,
der genauso immer wieder mal gesagt hat na ja hier so war WE und so die betreiben ja bestimmt Spionage für die Chinesen und wir können ja unsere 5g Telefonnetze und überhaupt alles nicht mit böser chinesischer Technologie machen weil
könnte ja sein dass die machen was wir machen wie wir aus den snow Dokumenten wissen ja und einfach mal überall Daten abziehen und wo kommen denn da hin.
Geht nicht das geht.
Werden das schon mal hier diskutiert auch unter diesem Aspekt Sicherheit und ist das überhaupt sagen sinnvoller Blick und hat man durch Heterogenität nicht sogar noch mehr Chancen et cetera pp jetzt brauchen wir überhaupt erstmal noch mal kurz aufgreifen was passiert ist.
Mirissa eine Sache eingefallen InDesign in diesen Diskussionen um den Ausschluss Waze,
aus dem Netzausbau in Deutschland hatte ich gesagt dass bei diesem vendor Mix üblicherweise der der Anteil,
Rasur im Bereich vielleicht 30 40% liegt ne und ich habe mich dann noch mal mit einigen Mobilfunknetzbetreiber unterhalten in Deutschland und es ist tatsächlich so dass in.
In Deutschland Imran also im radio access network also da.
Das was die Antennen auf den Dächern sind der Huawei Marktanteil bei einigen deutschen Netzbetreibern inzwischen in Richtung 80% geht.
Haben was damit zu tun hat dass die als einzige base stations machen die ihr Frequenzband,
unterschiedlich nutzen können also quasi bestimmte Frequenzen auf 2G und auf 3G und auf 5g,
je nach Auslastung und bedarf verwenden können ja so die die anderen Hersteller sind alle so okay du stellst hier Zweige Hindu Funktion Zweige auf der Frequenz 3G 4G
und war hat aber quasi All-in-One Komponenten gibt's von den anderen auch aber die können ihre
Frequenzen quasi auch dynamisch allozieren und können sagen ok in dem 800 Megahertz Bereich in dem ich jetzt gerade bin oder Deutschland wär es 902 also dass sie quasi sagen,
hier wo ich normalerweise GSM mache ich habe soviel Band für GSM.
Ich brauche aber gerade gar nicht soviel GSM jetzt. Ich auf dem Bereich auch ein bisschen 4G ja für mich ein bisschen älter und das können dynamisch zuordnen und das können die anderen nicht und das hat auch insbesondere zu dem zu der noch weiteren Markt,
Herrschaft huaweis,
beigetragen die also jetzt hier bei einigen Mobilfunknetzbetreiber in Deutschland wo in Richtung 80% geht im radio access network.
War mir bei dieser Anteil war mir neu und deswegen muss ich kurz rüber,
korrigieren werde auch aber darüber sprachen wie viel uhr Leben in unseren jetzigen Netzen schon drin ist und wie unsinnig das ist zu sagen die wollen wir im 5 gehen nicht haben oder wie unwahrscheinlich.
Aber,
Ware ist ja nicht nur in diesem Telekommunikationsbereich überhaupt präsenter das ist mittlerweile ein Riesenkonzern der in etwa zu vergleichen ist mit Samsung aus Südkorea
das heißt marie ist auch extrem stark im Smartphone Business ist glaube ich mittlerweile sogar Platzhirsch in China
ist auch im Laptop Markt vertreten also es gibt da im Prinzip alles Kinder sehr aggressiv Ohren haben natürlich,
die man sich vorstellen kann da ist das ihre ganzen Produktionskapazitäten auch noch im eigenen Land liegen da auch große Vorteile gegenüber anderen Unternehmen
und sind generell einfach sehr erfolgreich man könnte fast denken
das ist vielleicht auch ein Grund warum überhaupt gegen sie vorgegangen wird weil wir ja schon mehrfach diskutiert haben ist diese ganzen Security Debatte zwar auf einem bestimmten Ebene durchaus nachvollziehbar aber eigentlich,
geht alles was man theoretisch dagegen war wer sagen könnte,
genauso auch für alle anderen da kannst du auch gegen Cisco Vorbringen weil da steht wissen wir ja wir wissen es ja ja das,
solche Dinge gemacht worden und das generell auch kompromittierte Hardware,
auftauchen kann wo vielleicht noch nicht mal der Hersteller selber direkt die Finger mit im Spiel hat all das ist einfach keine Garantie für ein sicheres Netz nur derweil man auch welche Anbieter ausschließt.
Jetzt hat allerdings die USA die Daumenschrauben noch mal stärker,
angezogen und hat einen Telekommunikations Notstand ausgerufen und das wiederum wirft einen riesigen Schatten oder die ganze Geschichte weil es jetzt,
für Unternehmen die in den USA aktiv sind und das sind normal zwangsläufig alle globalen Unternehmen.
Diese jetzt eine,
Lizenz erwerben müssen wenn sie wahr wäre bestimmt Technologien verkaufen wollen wenn es zumindest einen gewissen Heim Anteil der USA von ich glaube 25% überschreitet das ist
bei vielen Halt gegeben insbesondere durch bei den amerikanischen Unternehmen.
Besonders also es gab es Ankündigung von Microsoft von Intel von Qualcomm sich zurückzuziehen und,
da wird schon kritisch auf verschiedenen Ebenen also Microsoft audible ist natürlich klar ne also war Wehrmacht
Laptops wollte jetzt auch gerade da ins Premium-Segment oder ist er schon ganz gut vorangekommen da wo das Geld zu verdienen ist
und jetzt kriegen sie mich keine Windows-Lizenz mehr und kann keine Intel Prozessoren erfahren dass quasi der Tod für diese Branche
aber genauso alt auch im Smartphone Bereich wo Google auch schon Rückzieher gemacht hat und sie jetzt nicht mehr in diesem Google PlayStore lässt damit also von Software Updates
ausschließt von der Google autorisierten Android Variante so das war wär zwar nach wie vor auf Android zurückgreifen kann,
es in Open Source Android aber eben auch auf nicht mehr als das und dann ist er Google PlayStore halt in Magna nennenswerte Bedeutung und Dominanz hat ist es schwierig.
Und unter Google diese gesamte Google
Einbindung von Android ist das wo die Sicherheit dann herkommt ne also dass viele der Sicherheitsfunktionen von Android hast du deshalb weil du diese Google Anbindung hast.
Also irgendwie stört die sich nicht die Signatur Ketten für die app und irgendwelche sie haben das t-watch irgendwas Fall bottle gibt irgendsoein monitoring
Security Tool für Android was auch alles aus diesem Winnenden,
Unglück in den Morast nur selten abgestiegen aber viele der Sicherheitsfeatures die du als Android-Nutzer genießen kannst genießt du durch spezifisch diese YouTube ein diese Google Einbindungen.
Eichwalde mich Google auch vor einigen Jahren ja dazu übergegangen ist über diesen PlayStore security updates auch auszuliefern bestimmte für so Frameworks etc die davor
nur per Betriebssystem Update geliefert werden konnten und das ging ja dann entsprechend langsamer mehr ja auch schon oft diskutiert weil die Hersteller kein großes Interesse daran haben Security außerdem,
kostenlos Geld.
Der dickste Brocken jetzt allerdings ist die Ankündigung von armen sich auch diesen Telekommunikations Notstandsgesetze da zu beugen,
und hier wird wirklich windig warm ist ja nun
ein britisches Unternehmen hat aber selber in USA genug Operation Texas sind die glaube ich unter Annahmen paar andere Standorte auch noch und sehen sich jetzt hier quasi auch gezwungen.
Gegenüber war wieder heiß aktive Verträge Ansprüche auf Support und anhängige Verabredungen fallenzulassen.
Das ist natürlich ein hartes Ding unklar inwieweit die Lizenzen jetzt selber für die ARM-Architektur hiervon betroffen sind wie viele Hersteller,
baut VW eigene Prozessoren für ihre Smartphones da beziehen sie sich dann in der Regel auf
sogenannte Referenz Designs von Arm also Arm ist ja an sich erstmal nur eine Prozessorarchitektur wo generell gesagt wird wie ein Prozessoren System funktioniert Befehlssätze RC,
und außerdem liefern sie mit den sogenannten cortex
System auch immer so konkrete Bauanleitung quasi ne also hier ist und reich Tektur und schau mal wenn du das so alles zusammen stoppst dann erfüllst du dich nur alle Antwort und dieser Architektur sein dann kriegst du relativ schnell auch ein funktionierendes System da kannst du dann noch deinen ganzen
systemspezifische nen Kram dazu ballern Massenstart raus und fertig ist die Laube so agieren nahezu alle
Anbieter auf dem Markt mit der großen Ausnahme von
Apple Apple ist ja ein direkter Architektur Lizenznehmer und macht alles selber sie machen das komplette Design selber das Spiel aber an dieser Stelle auch überhaupt gar keine Rolle auf jeden Fall,
könnte das bedeuten das Wahre.
Jetzt nicht mehr der Lage ist Abend passierte Komponenten in ihren Prozessoren in ihren also ihren systemschutz bzw seid überhaupt in ihren Systemen zu verbauen,
was soviel bedeutet wie sie können überhaupt nichts mehr bauen weil heutzutage ist am einfach überall also.
Extrem wenig Bereiche heutzutage an Computertechnik wo nicht arm Technologie drinsteckt es ist fast nichts was ist ein nur noch dann verstehe ich nur noch die Intel Laptop Welt.
Und deshalb Welt und aller kleinste Systeme wo,
derzeit noch einen Arm Chip schon fast zuviel wäre aber das verschwindet auch in zunehmendem Maße der Arm ist die Welt der Computer heutzutage und da ist natürlich so ein Zugriff der USA wirklich bedenkt.
Ja was kann man daraus ziehen also.
Erstmal ist es wirklich erstaunlich wie viel,
ein Fluss die US-Regierung hier über solche Druckmittel hat auf die globale Wirtschaft.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher ob sie sich jetzt so wie Freunde machen mit dieser ganzen Nummer weil irgendwann wirst du ihn dann auch mal reichen und ich glaube da gibt es genug Hebel wo China den USA.
Eine Menge Ärger machen kann,
sicherlich auch auf Kosten ihrer eigenen Wirtschaft aber wenn die ohnehin leidet dann wird irgendwann so ein Punkt erreicht sein wo die einfach sagen so scheiß drauf jetzt machen wir euch fertig und das wird sicherlich nicht lustig,
man muss sich natürlich auch fragen ist das sozusagen jetzt auch mal einen.
Ein eine Schwäche des Wirtschaftssystem San sich.
Diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten ist technologischen Abhängigkeiten von Global verfügbaren Technologien die dann auf einmal weil ein Land durchdreht und sich irgendwie mal wieder den Diktator dujour als Mikrofon gestellt hat.
Alle mit hops nehmen wie du darüber denkst aber das ist.
Ich habe die Diskussion gesehen naja wir müssen halt mir auch bis Horstmar schöner Gedanke,
so ja nur haben wir ja gesehen wie sehr opens house in der Lage ist das Rattenrennen
an der Spitze der Entwicklung mitzuhalten das geht nur sehr eingeschränkt außer Linux
hat sich ja eigentlich nicht sehr viel entwickelt das auf jeden Fall schon mal sehr gut weil im Prinzip an der Stelle,
die ganze Software-Architektur von Servern stückweit FlyTampa Desktops gesichert ist aber es halt auch nur ein kleiner Rand.
Na da bin ich ein bisschen widersprechen also Open-Source hat sich schon denke ich als das Paradigma,
für Softwareentwicklung allgemein durchgesetzt so Linux Android,
der meiste webcam GitHub ist ein unglaublich florierender.
Base und du brauchst eigentlich als Entwickler nirgendwo großartig dich zu bewerben wenn du nicht substantiell.
Vorzeigbares GitHub Repo gitterprofil mit ordentlichen repose vor zeigst ja Open-Source hat sich hier schon durchaus
als das
vorherrschende Paradigma etabliert nur es ist nicht das Open-Source von dem irgendwie so Leute wie Richard Stallman irgendwelche.
Hippie Lieder singen und davon ausgehen dass dass das jetzt hier alles von von von uns in unserer Freizeit irgendwie geil geschrieben wird und diese Free Software
dass das antikapitalistische wäre was es überhaupt gibt OpenSource wird,
vorangetrieben weil es sinnvoll ist für die Unternehmen die es betreiben so Google
treibt Open-Source Entwicklung voran weil es sinnvoll für die Pläne ist die google hat Facebook treibt die Open-Source Entwicklung insbesondere Linux und solche Scherze voran weil die dieses Server betreiben,
die sind doch die sind froh.
Diesen OpenSource Bereich stark zu dominieren und davon zu profitieren gleichzeitig sind die natürlich haben wir auch einen massiven Einfluss da rein wenn,
finde dir jetzt mal überlegst dass der größere Teil des der Linux Entwicklung vielleicht von sagen wir mal Google.
Facebook und RedHat irgendwie vorangetrieben würde na dann ist es natürlich auch klar dass ich dieses Betriebssystem gemäß der Anforderungen entwickelt und dann profitieren die alle voneinander und,
also ich würde sagen ob es was hat sich durch sehr durchgesetzt ist das,
vorherrschende Paradigma der Softwareentwicklung weil es eben auch zu,
kapitalistisch gerade für die Unternehmen das sinnvollste ist so zu arbeiten wenn er gar kein Interesse daran ihren welche proprietären besonderen Server Betriebssysteme vorzuhaltende.
Wie gesagt im Serverbereich und in der Beck in Infrastruktur ist das so aber auf dem Desktop ist das überhaupt,
ich so es gibt da keinen nicht im Ansatz irgendetwas OpenSource iges was wirklich für Applikationen Anwendung Betriebssysteme die User facing sind in irgendeiner Form Konkurrenz darstellen und
im Kontext dieser aktuellen war wie Diskussion muss ich sagen man muss auch sehen,
hoffe ist auch nur ein Teil eines Computers und ein extrem wichtiger Teil ist und bleibt die Hardware und die darin versenkte Software,
und hier ist OpenSource mäßig fast nicht da also es gibt
natürlich gibt es Open Source Hardware Projekte wie heißt diese neueste risk Architekturgeschichte Spark oder so ich weiß es jetzt gerade nicht auswendig also es gibt da kleinere Projekte wo zahlst du dich
Open Source Hardware Stick Touren durchgesetzt werden oder entwickelt werden nur.
Durchgesetzt hat sich Arm es ist absehbar dass auf die nächsten zehn Jahre haben einfach das beherrschende wenn ich gar,
was einzige die Factor einzige System ist es ist nicht so schlimm wie die Abhängigkeit die wir lange Zeit von Intel hatten weil da ist halt,
bedeutet halt du kannst dann auch die Chips nur von Insel kaufen bei Arm ist es ja anders denn die designen in Anführungsstrichen nur die Architektur.
Optional kannst du dann eben wie schon erwähnt habe auch die fertigen Designs kaufen kannst aber im Prinzip einfach nur die Einstieg Tour lizensieren und von da ab alles selbermachen,
wenn aber jetzt schon diese Lizensierung an dieser Stelle von so einer wirtschaftlichen politischen wirtschaftlichen Vorstoß der USA gefährdet wird.
Reißt das sozusagen das Gefüge der Welt Technologieentwicklung vollständig auseinander und wenn die USA der Meinung ist sie müsste das jetzt noch weiter vorantreiben denke ich mal wird sich hier
schnell eine neue Bewegung bilden müssen die einfach fragt.
Wie kann man das verhindern was was können wir auch für internationale Regelungen finden es schreit ja auch weiß ich.
Bin ich ganz sicher welche internationale Organisation an dieser Stelle angerufen werden könnte aber schreit natürlich hier auch nach einem
eine Verzerrung des globalen Wettbewerbs par excellence und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass es jetzt komplett Nations' frei sein dürfte nur die USA damit der wieder unbedingt umgeht ist ein offenes,
für Leute die es und war weh Handy haben sieht das jetzt erstmal kurzfristig nicht so gut aus weil das sieht jetzt danach aus als ob das so mit den security updates extrem schwierig werden dürfte,
ähnliches könnte auch für die Laptops gelten habe ich mir jetzt gerade nicht ganz so sicher so oder so ist das alles nicht schön.
Ich bin mal gespannt wie wow way.
Glaube nicht unbedingt dass das jetzt so baue in einer strategischen Situation.
In eine strategische Situation bringt die sie nicht antizipiert haben und da die eh alles für,
Deutschland gebaut haben für den Westen gebaut haben für die USA gebaut haben und all dieses Wissen ohnehin schon haben.
Bin ich noch nicht mal sicher.
Ob dieser dieser dieser Wirtschaftskrieg nicht viel zu spät angezettelt wird um ihn noch zu gewinnen ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen dass wir jetzt einfach die Schublade aufmacht.
Und da ihre eigenen Designs für sagen wir Baseband Prozessoren sagen wir von mir aus auch am artige
Prozessoren und was nicht alles aus dem Hut zaubert,
ich habe einen Markenname für ein eigenes operating system wurde ja sogar jetzt schon registriert hörte platteter an mir vorbei.
Ich kann mir vorstellen ja dass das.
Das Trump sich hier tatsächlich sogar noch verzockt wäre und war ja jetzt quasi sagen wir mal nicht mit 1 Jahr nicht so geile Gewinne macht weil sie
mal eben noch die ganzen alten Abhängigkeiten abschneiden müssen die sie zur Befriedung,
der USA noch irgendwie aufrecht erhalten haben und gesagt haben ja ja kommen während wir hier die Welt Bäckerei werden kriegt ihr noch ein kleines Stück vom Kuchen immer absolut ist schon in Ordnung super ne wir schneiden nicht die,
die Hand ab die der beißt nicht in die Hand die uns hier irgendwie gerade nähert und füttert und ich bin mal gespannt ob war hier.
Überhaupt nennenswert unter Druck ist also im Sinne von vom Ruin bedroht.
Oder ob die sagen wunderbar Befreiungsschlag die einzige Sache ich meine das Risiko ist natürlich dass Sie eventuell ihren Kram halt dann einfach in im Westen als nächstes,
doch gar nicht mehr verkaufen dürfen.
Das wäre natürlich dann etwas was die durchaus treffen würde aber dann bin ich mal gespannt wie lange Tim guckt sich das anguckt wenn er auf einmal keine iPhones mehr nach China liefern darf.
Also hier wird immer so berichtet als wäre das jetzt irgendwie ein Angriff auf war und wäre nicht in der Lage sich zu verteidigen und ich glaube da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ob's nicht in China ein paar Leute sitzt die schon längst Strategien für diese für diese Eskalation haben und gerade sagen dass kostens ehrlich gesagt ein müdes arschrunzeln ist E-Mails durch,
dann fahren wir es halt die Defense hoch.
Wobei sich ja interessanter Weise gerade war wer der Chef von war wer dafür eingesetzt hat das Apple auf gar keinen Fall bestraft wird
weil das sein das Unternehmen ist was mit dem sie die allerbesten Beziehung haben und ja der wahre Chef meinte so ja Apple sei ja sein Mentor.
Ja also dass das,
ist jetzt eine Apple spezifische Geschichte Apple hat sich halt extrem für China ein Gesetz in letzten Jahren und da einfach gute Beziehung aufgebaut
das wird sie sicherlich jetzt noch ein bisschen vor etwas schützen aber ist ja auch nicht so dass sie nicht alle anderen Unternehmen auch in China bauen würden und wie gesagt
könnte schon schwierig sein wenn China hat sagt ne okay dann halt nicht,
so sieht mal zu wo er ein Scheiß her kriegt dann gibt's jetzt hier mal ordentlich Zöller dann wird es aber schön teuer morgen mal gucken wie das mit dem Ausbau eurer Telekommunikation so läuft also ich denke auch dass China hier
letztlich den längeren Hebel haben wird wir uns das noch nicht so richtig vorstellen können weil wir eh alle keine Ahnung haben andererseits denke ich,
lern China hier auch.
Den Westen noch mal neu kennen nicht dass sie das nicht schon immer geahnt haben aber ich glaube die Chinesen wissen am Ende mehr über uns als wir über sie.
Und dementsprechend dürfte das noch eine Rocky road werden insofern natürlich auch interessant wie sich hier Europa positioniert,
und Deutschland natürlich auch also wir hatten das ja auch schon mal erwähnt dass hier auch schon so erste Ideen kamen da,
usada im Fahrwasser zu folgen aber ich glaube das wäre eine ganz schlechte Idee und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es jetzt auch eine Chance,
von Europa zu sagen so.
Ja Wettbewerb okay alles klar Sicherheit müssen wir auf jeden Fall drüber reden aber hier so Notstand auszurufen ist einfach mal affig und albern
den Spaß machen wir jetzt nicht mit Liebe swawa ihr dürft ihr gerne mit ein paar Auflagen weiterverkaufen wir kommen aber weiterhin klar ich denke das ist auch derzeit.
USA wird in zunehmendem Maße isoliert werden und was diesen Teil.
Sommer wohin sich das entwickelt.
Komme zum paar Kurzmeldungen und da mal endlich mal unseren alten Freund Schäuble mal wieder.
Also das ist.
Das ist ja auch so ein Thema ne dass das wirste nicht los.
Du bist nicht bei der CDU.
Nee weil der Tage bei der bei der CDU wirklich nicht das ist und interessanterweise.
Sag mal was das Thema ist.
Klarnamenpflicht,
ja kann ja wohl nicht sein dass das jeder hier im Internet einfach irgendwas sagt ohne seinen Namen dran zu schreiben ja da müsste unser lieber Herr Schäuble.
Dem reicht's jetzt wir haben das dass es offen Themen das haben wir hier irgendwann das haben wir so oft behandelt ich denke nicht also erstens sehen wir nicht dass die Klarnamenpflicht unbedingt.
Den Anstand der Menschen bei ihren Äußerungen nennenswert steigert ja es ist nicht so dass die ätherischen verleumderischen,
sexistischen rassistischen Äußerungen nur aus dem Schutz der Anonymität,
getätigt werden ganz im Gegenteil kann man sich auf Facebook anschauen wie die Leute da,
ohne den Schutz der Anonymität ihren Hass verbreiten und ihre Drohung aussprechen bis erst I.
Zeiten denke ich auch das natürlich eine für eine Auseinandersetzung sollte es auch keine Rolle spielen ob das Argument.
Vorgetragen wird von unter Klarnamen oder nicht effektiv sollte immer das Argument zählen,
natürlich ist es wird viel damit gespielt mit mit,
Labels was heißt ich wir sind jetzt hier der Bundesverband der so und so ne dann wir sind ja sowieso Experte um irgendwie den Eindruck zu vermitteln dass das was man hier sagt Hand und Fuß hat aber gerade in diesem beleidigungs Bereich und in diesem
Bereich auf den Teufel sich hier bezieht spiele der erst recht keine Rolle da kann ich mir ja auch durchaus da daran dass die Meinung,
anonym geäußert wurde
oder pseudonym geäußert wurde das eben auch in meiner Bewertung miteinbeziehen und sagen guck mal hier das ist irgendein das ist irgendjemand der schreibt noch nicht mal Namen dran der steht noch nicht mal der schämt sich sogar selber dafür was er sagt ja auch das ja irgendwie.
Ein einen eine Kuh der mit einer Rolle spielt also ich sehe überhaupt nicht was was das soll ich sehe dass das sehe noch nicht einmal dass es in irgendeiner Form das Ziel erreichen würde zu mehr Anstand im Netz zu führen und ich sehe,
natürlich den den ganzen,
Kollateralschaden noch und nöcher der mit sowas einhergehen würde braucht man eigentlich nicht mehr zu diskutieren.
Dann mach mal das jetzt auch nie.
Machen wir auch nicht.
Auch nicht diskutieren müsste man diese ganze Geschichte rundum passenger Name record also die Flug Vorratsdatenspeicherung das war ja eine,
europäische Entscheidung eine solche vorzunehmen das heißt alle Daten die anfallen wenn man.
Fliegt innerhalb von Europa oder auch außerhalb von Europa müssen von den Airlines vorgehalten werden und uns falls Versand halt auch an die Behörden weiter geliefert werden.
Jetzt gibt's Berichte.
Dass das nicht so gut läuft so sagen darf denn die Überwachung von Flugpassagieren liefert vor allem Fehler.
Okay.
Also die.
Es ging im letzten Jahr los das ist Bundeskriminalamt diese ganzen Daten geholt hat und,
dann bricht heiß ist das auf jeder korrekte verdachtsmeldung mehr als 400 falsche Treffer kommen also so diese Klassiker mit ähnlichen Namen mit ca und man hofft halt hier nach verdächtigen Mustern suchen zu können dass diese ganze
Heuraufen Stecknadel Theorie das wenn man nur den Haufen groß genug macht dass man dann die Nadel besser finden kann
unten sieht also nicht so aus als ob das so gut läuft.
Es gibt auch eine neue Initiative von Bürgerrechtlern die jetzt noch mal gegen diese Auswertung von Passagierdaten stoppen diese diese,
wollen vorgehen wollen genau und bereiten hier irgendwie insgesamt glaube ich 6 Klagen gegen diese Speicherung vor dahintersteckt die Gesellschaft für,
Freiheitsrechte und andere Gruppen und Job kann dir dann nur.
Unterstützung wünschen wir linken da mal drauf.
Und hast du schon mal deine Domain falsch eingegeben in deinem Telekom DSL Internet.
Ich habe keinen Telekom DSL.
Alarm doch Telekom.de.
Nee ich habe keinen Telekom DSL Internet weil wenn man da eine Domain falsch eingibt kommt man sofort auf irgend so eine komische Navigationshilfe Seite und das stört irgendwie meine der stört mich.
Ein Euphemismus Navigationshilfe dass ich keine Hilfe wenn.
Behinderung.
Die totale Behinderung ich glaube wer hat da mit mal angefangen hier dieser nicht verreisen die Serben.
Zertifikate Anbieter VeriSign war das glaube ich als erstes die irgendwie sehen den USA da entsprechende Zugänge erschlichen haben also was passiert du gibst in deinem Browser eine Domain falsche ein.
Ja schreibst also nicht Logbuch Netzpolitik Logbuch Witz Politik und dann,
stellt ja dann sollte ja das Internet zu sagen feststellen dass diese Domain noch niemand registriert hat da wird dann von deinem Computer aus ja immer gefragt okay,
hier werden für de zuständig und Kind Handy Computer die die Auskunft Informationen haben,
für de kennen Sie diese Domain und wenn ja,
möchte ich gerne wissen welcher Computer hierfür wiederum Adressen und sonstige Informationen aus Gebiet zu dieser Domain gehören und wenn das nicht der Fall ist also wenn es sozusagen niemanden gibt der dafür zuständig ist spricht die Domain nicht existiert.
Dann gibt es eine Fehlermeldung.
Oder Sport der sich dann halt so eingeführt hat bei den Providern das hat auch die Telekom so gemacht ist dass sie dann diese letzte Fehlermeldung war sie geschluckt haben gesagt haben.
Also wenn sie du mir nicht gibt dann können wir das doch einfach sein und haben das dann einfach in dem Moment auf ihre eigene blöde Back-End
Webseite mit diesem bekloppten Namen Navigationshilfe was wir wollen den Leuten ja helfen ja wenn,
Anmeldung sehen und so dann sind wir alle verloren und stattdessen checken Sie das Ganze und Blende natürlich dann auch Werbung ein oder andere,
Boote und so weiter und ist schon und da ist jetzt so selten nicht vorkommt
war das natürlich ein Schmerz sagazan immer Proteste dagegen und hatte Dich konnte man das dann auch irgendwann ausschalten musste man natürlich auch erstmal Ausschalten also alles so ob der auch bis dann irgendwie so
ja unten im Keller III Tür wo drauf steht Vorsicht bissiger Leopard da darfst du dann reingehen und freundlich fragen das doch mal ausgeschaltet wird spricht bist du da diese simsen Schalter gefunden hast,
dauert es lange die meisten Leute wussten ja noch nicht mal dass es so ist nun findet das ganze ein Ende die Telekom muss dieses sogenannte DNS Hijacking,
beende oder hattest du gar bereits beendet weil einfach mal einen Benutzer Strafanzeige gestellt hat,
weil nämlich wenn man sich das technisch anschaut auf diese Art und Weise sich die Telekom ja quasi die Hoheit über andere Domains erschleicht und.
Theoretisch auch auf gespeicherte Cookies auf dem Rechner Zugriff erhalten kann und das ganze,
wurde er jetzt sozusagen mal auf dem Klageweg weggehauen und.
Was ist abschalten jetzt.
Muss jetzt mal abschalten weil ich nicht ne.
Telekom meint allerdings die Strafanzeige wäre ja überhaupt nicht ausschlaggebend gewesen sollen sie hätten ja schon 2019 also im April,
2019 anschreiben der Bundesnetzagentur zu diesem Thema bekommen dass ich auf eine Verbraucherbeschwerde bezog und,
haben wir dann beantwortet und dann haben wir halt gesagt dass ist abgeschaltet haben nein also es war jetzt überhaupt nicht ans Jahre lang betrieben und dann nie ein Problem gesehen und auf einmal ganz eine Verbraucherbeschwerde und auf einmal sind die Leute darauf eingegangen,
ich weiß nicht wie oft ich dir schon irgendwie angeraunzt habe deswegen aber ich war wohl nicht ausreichend hab und ich genug verbraucht bei denen tschüss bye bye.
Und eine Sache noch in dieser ganzen Debatte um die datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Und auch in dem schönen Gespräch Festival Logbuch Netzpolitik 256 onstage mit Jan-Philipp.
Jan Philipp Albrecht.
Manfred Albrecht geführt haben
über die datenschutzgrundverordnung die ja damals gerade in Kraft getreten ist jetzt ein Jahr alt ist ganz immer so diese lauernde Frage mit der Grund okay ist das jetzt so sein das neue Einfallstor für Abmahner.
Und es gab da sehr unterschiedliche Einschätzungen von Anwälten wohin da die Reise gehen können auch wenn die Mehrheit meinte seine geht eigentlich nicht weil es Privatrecht und nicht Wettbewerbsrecht cetera
es gab dann eine erste entscheidung beim Landgericht in Würzburg was tatsächlich gesagt hat ja nee kann man abmahnen und,
hing wohl seitdem bisschen offen gibt's gibt's eine neue Entscheidung diesmal vom Landgericht Stuttgart die ganz anderer Meinung sind hier gab es eine klare eines
Verband von online Unternehmern die sich irgendwo gegen die haben missbraucht ne
Wettbewerb richtig durchsetzen wollten und halt versucht haben da so einen kraftfahrzeugzubehör Händler auf Ebay entsprechen abzumahnen weil angeblich nicht alle datenschutz-grundverordnung Dinge,
richtig genannt sind keiner sein und das Urteil des Landgerichts sagt.
Bitte dichtmachen dsgvo Verstöße sind vor abmahnmissbrauch geschützt wir verlinken hier.
Weil weil weil die Strafen quasi in der dsgvo benannt sind das ist gerade das ist ab ausreichend geklärt und.
Noch keine guten gute Nachrichten zum.
Gut dann ist die weiter gute Nachricht das jetzt am Ende der Sendung angelangt sind.
Dudas.
Wie geht's mit Union weiter Trainer feuern.
Oder was was willst du noch wie das jetzt jetzt darfst du noch ein bisschen von Union reden wenn Du möchtest.
Pertussi teuer.
Weiß ich nicht vielleicht.
Na ich freue mich sehr,
dieser doch sehr besondere Vereinen diesmal ein mehr Licht mehr Licht auf ihn bestrahlt wird weil ich denke das ne ganze Menge zu holen und Alpha die Leute die mit Fußball was anfangen können,
Bundesliga sich einerseits warm anziehen und andererseits gibt's auch viel Interessantes zu entdecken und wir haben es auf Hawaii ein Jahr Spaß,
Urlaub Fußball Urlaub.
Dann sind wir im danke Bereich angekommen und ich danke dieses Mal dem Erik sehr verspätet Dank.
Den üblichen ey du hast ein Paket öffne Paket bei uns naja ich ein Paket Problem dem Niklas und der Anna herzlichen Dank.
Und allen Spendern und regelmäßigen Unterstützern vorne logbuch-netzpolitik das war's für diese Woche wir sagen tschüss und bis bald.